welcome everybody to another
entrepreneur am a business Q&A helping
answer business questions I am getting
set to get my game on here with let me
close us down with J reyez birthday boy
j rise in the house and trainer 6 is
back today after skipping out on
yesterday so i'm excited and of course
my usual co-host rishi kept TV welcome
back hi guys i'm feeling the love the
chat is already on fire happy happy
tuesday everyone alright i love it well
who do we have in a chat we got trained
or six we got Jen we got Zeno rise
online it's a good start yeah there it's
blowing up this rishi this might be a
sniping one to watch today this might be
interesting challenge keep the Munson
added popped in oh the mosque is here to
keeping up with all these chatters
what's in a cup today I'm just going to
close my blinds here but you you tell us
what's in the cup great yes today I've
got my I've got my Spanish skeptical
Michigan this morning and I'm feeling a
cup of believe I'm actually wearing my
Evan Carmichael believe shirt this
morning so I got an extra dose of go out
in the world and make an impact extra
dose of belief I'm feeling it I've got
my usual I already finished my vitamin
water so on to tea with honey and
smoothie and water and all that stuff
are you feeling hey I'm feeling like I'm
gonna go Evelyn today instead of team oh
oh you're feeling okay today I'm feeling
the change today Evelyn was the one that
we did the backup champion that i
did--like number of episodes ago we'll
see we'll see we'll see depends on how
the team comp works out but we'll see
anyway we are setting up for a game and
let's hope we get a birthday
in for j rise and let's get to some
quiet with that yeah happy birthday to j
reyez the chat was asking for for me to
serenade but i'll have to do that
serenade another day oh you are a song
the chat was blowing it up for happy
birthday song forge a ride okay I'm
Emmett should we say I think you should
do that okay me me me me me me me you're
not gonna join me in a song and going
solo on this all right hmm yeah petty
are we really doing you are we gonna do
it of course I already started I thought
I was going alone okay why I'm good good
23 happy birthday to you I'm doing it
solo happy birthday to you happy
birthday I which is here dear j wride
day happy birthday
there we go the love the Alex love to
spend some of he didn't want me to do it
solo there we go cool happy birthday Jay
all right first question comes from vibe
have and vibe hug says hi I'm confused
at this stage of my life I need your
help please make a video on how to
differentiate differentiate between bold
strategic risk investment and greedy
gamble so yeah it's an interesting
question and I don't know exactly what
you're wanting to apply these different
things too but it sounds like he wants a
little bit of feedback on maybe the
extreme of when you're starting a
business you can either start with you
know taking bold risks asking for
investments or I guess greedy gamble
could mean that you're the other extreme
like relying too much on other people's
money I'm not really sure that I
understand the question but we've got a
great episode specifically on investment
and that's episode 5 and I think it
would at least be a great place to start
to get a little bit more education on
when it's the right time to ask for an
investment and when it's you know most
of the time it's the right thing to you
know just boots drop it and and take
some I don't know if you want to call it
risk but I know that investment is
usually not in the early stages of the
business so I'd say check out check out
episode 5 what with a 3 bold strategic
risk
investment and greg campbell yeah i
really think it just depends on You Man
I mean for for looking at like people
may look at what I'm doing and feel like
that's a greedy thing or that's just an
investment or like any of the three
could apply from an outsider's
perspective I think for you it's just
feeling comfortable in your own skin and
knowing you're doing it for the right
reasons right like why do I want to help
a billion entrepreneurs why am i why am
i right in the book is that is that just
a greedy thing that I want to do well
some people will see it that way is that
a bold investment well maybe it's just
something that aligns with my mission I
feel like I need to do probably I think
it just I think it's just up to you i
think i think as long as you're doing
things i think the intent matters you
know in all the stuff that you're doing
the intent matters for the big decisions
in life but also the small ones are you
you know seen yes to this deal because
it's really important for you and it
aligns with your mission are you saying
yes to this deal just to try to make
some money are you saying yes to this
deal just to screw somebody else over
are you saying yes to this deal just to
help somebody else the intent matters
and i think only you can judge why
you're doing it and hopefully you have
the right intent I mean we've talked
about it a number of times in this
channel about when you're certain the
business you want to do it because
you're trying to help because you're
trying to add value because you want to
make an impact and through that you'll
make your money with the people who just
try to start a business to make money
fail typically and so that's it like
what do you feel in your heart do you
feel greedy I don't feel greedy doing my
book or doing this dream or doing my
youtube channel if you feel greedy then
maybe you shouldn't do it or maybe you
just have a limited
mindset you know maybe maybe that fear
being greedy has held you back a lot you
know maybe your fear being greedy has
prevented you from doing some super
important things in your life because
you're worried about how the people
judge you or how you judge yourself so
for all three of those things that it's
really just intent that's it that's what
I got good point alright next question
comes from Jason and Jason says I have
aspirations to one day open online poker
site as well as a Forex broker but I
have no experience no contacts I know
you're not big on excuses but I really
don't have any needs to know more
researching on Google is just not smart
at all could you please help me and
point me in the right place to look for
this kind of info we want to be an
online he must have an online poker site
and be a Forex broker and doesn't want
to look for information on Google I'm
trying to figure out you're not want to
look on google because you you know
Google comes up with a lot of weird
stuff or is it anyway that's another
story I think what's anything like this
if you're not one to kind of help
educate on the internet you might want
to find people in your local area who
are already doing what you're doing you
know I online poker site you might just
want to start by finding not necessarily
an online poker site but a poker playing
community in your area because for
anything for anything else you can begin
to start finding potential clients for
whatever you do have an online poker
site
have any you know people who are going
to be interested in your site so I think
for the poker site either you'd be great
to start with your poker local poker
community and just kind of see what
happens there you may also find use your
partnerships if other people who'd be
interested in being a part of this poker
site for eck forex broker I mean that
would be I know there's lots of
information online about that there
seems to be a tons of educational videos
that seem legit online about being a
forex broker so idle I don't know not
sure I would know where else to point
you for that other than your again kind
of reaching out to people in your local
area who you could talk to and get more
from all right well our team is uh just
died twice not the greatest start um he
wants to start a casino an online casino
and do and do forex is that if you want
to do like an online poker yes online
poker site and for it so my my initial
thought is why I'm thinking why do you
want to do this why is it important to
you why both the easy thing to say I
think about is it's just for the money
pick two industries where there's you
know high margins trying to make a lot
of money I'm so you know our usual
response about money being the reason to
do something
I think there's a lot of luck with
anything else you need to get experience
and figure it out right like in my
gratitude stream I mentioned Tim
Schmoyer I was doing YouTube I wanted to
figure out how to get better and so I
connected with I've never I didn't meet
him at the time but I subscribed his
youtube channel I learned this
strategies I I subscribe to a bunch of
other people to on youtube then I didn't
oh I'm gonna die I gotta get out of here
I didn't learn so much from and that's
part of the game right like who do you
talk to who do you trust would you
listen to you know I guess you watch my
channel and you've learned some things
from it so you want to write in and lets
you know humbly and I appreciate that
but the you know the the search for
knowledge has to continue poom poom you
have to go and educate yourself on I
would pick one the stark as both of
those are huge things that like to have
success to really be at the top of your
game at least at the start pick one that
you can really focus on but whichever
one it is maybe you don't know which one
go and go and subscribe to people's
YouTube channels and go look and yeah a
lot of the stuff on Google maybe crap
but there's going to be some stuff that
will help you to just like again the
team choix your model there they were
like maybe 15 different youtube experts
that I subscribe to not anymore but I
did when I was looking for information
and tim was my favorite by far Daryl
leaves I learned a couple things from
and everybody else was not helpful not
interesting not useful not valuable you
know maybe sharing that either the same
information or information I didn't
trust and that's part of the process at
the same time like Tim gives you
strategies on how to the tips and tricks
of YouTube but I needed to learn how to
be a better communicator as well so I
have a media coach who taught me how to
be
better on camera and I practiced with
her and I tried to study Les Brown in
from here I learned a lot about speaking
as well and so from all these people I
learned multiple different things that
could help me be better at my craft and
at the same time like so to find Les
Brown just like with Tim I had to go
through a bunch of people who were not
great we're not helpful for me so that's
what you like that's if you don't know
anything about the industry you have to
go and learn because you guarantee if
you go out and start spending money
trying to figure out how to do a casino
you're gonna blow a ton of money and
won't see any of that back because
you're just making a ton of mistakes not
because you're not smart just because
you don't know what you're doing yet and
you'll figure it out with experience it
seemed to go get that experience if
you're really fully committed to it like
this is really what you want to do then
I would go and try to find while doing
all this while researching and learning
and improving your skills and subscribe
on YouTube channels and model and
success I would try to find a job in a
an existing online casino that you love
whoa that you know about am I gonna die
am I gonna die am I gonna die I'm gonna
die now I'm not gonna die yet right um
so you can learn about the industry
whose one that you look up to and
respect and you want to be like and then
go learn go learn from them but yeah you
got it like I'm not the guy who can
teach you about Forex or casinos I can
teach about business but not the
specifics of those industries so you
need to go and find the guys girls who
who can and then and it sucks like I
hear you like you know Google doesn't
have the information or your you know
I'm assuming you've done some research
already and you're frustrated that's
part of the game finding the right
mentors for you is part of the game
so just keep going don't get the scourge
of the first one so you come across
aren't perfect fits yeah we've got a de
Massa given some value here he said I'd
suggest you start trading Forex on a
small scale first and then learn the
regulation and we've got some other
people in the chat thing they're excited
too they like starting their day with
this LOL am a well I like start my day
with you guys so it's a win-win
absolutely alright next question comes
from Zachary Zachary is in his own words
a want wreck preneur alright and but
he's trying to find his calling he wants
to do creative work that impacts the
world in a big way and allows him to
socialize and doesn't require extra
school because he hates the current
education system he's watching yeah so
he was a couple of your videos on
passion and purpose and but he says I'm
still lost I know I'm smart and
energetic enough to make something
happen but I don't know what field to to
be in or what skills to picked up and
I'm currently doing web design but I
can't see that changing the world how do
I figure out what I want to pursue so
yeah Zachary love that you are want to
preneur and it sounds like you've got
many talents many abilities and I
definitely we've talked about this
yesterday it just could be really a
challenge when you have a lot of
interests you're a creative person
you probably are going to be good at a
lots of different things and then how do
you narrow it into you know something
that you can tangibly and practically
start working on right now I think I
just start with we've talked about this
a lot i know but i would just start with
you know what do you want to do right
now that makes you come alive and don't
think of it as if I make this choice
it's going to be the decision that is
for the rest of my life because nowadays
it's the norm to try something and move
on and try something and move on and
trust me and whereas them in the past if
that might have looked at an unwise
decision for your career it's actually
something now that is more and more
comment I would just start with what
makes you come alive you know maybe you
don't have to start a business around it
but get involved with with another
organization you know work for someone
and who may have a mission that you can
get on board with another entrepreneur
would be awesome you know support
another entrepreneur and start there and
learn what it is to be an entrepreneur
learn what makes you come alive and then
I think over time you will get more and
more clear on the specific business that
you want to start
alright more thing to one more thing i
would i would suggest the chase jarvis
interview because there's a lot of
really cool nuggets of wisdom that is in
the interview with evan and chase jarvis
so as a creative person you definitely
might want to check out that interview
it's called entrepreneurs your intuition
is your friend okay yeah that I think
that'd be great just in interview for
inspiration I love chase man that's good
well while I happen I got a triple kills
I got three kills I'm pretty excited
about that um a good little team fight
there um so the two I've two thoughts
around this first I agree with I agree
with Rishi you need to explore explore
explore explore until you find the thing
that makes you come alive it's great
that you know what you don't like that's
it that's an amazing start you know you
don't like sitting in the classroom
awesome you know but now you need to
continue to try new things until you
find something that you do like just
like as I was talking to my gratitude
stream this morning about trying to
dance salsa you know I didn't know if I
would like salsa or not you know again
on paper didn't look like it be
something that would be good for me but
I ended up really liking it and I
wouldn't have known unless I tried and
so sometimes you need to just go out and
try uh I died very sad we gotta kill but
I died um so try look you get an idea
for something I wish that I could do
whatever right just go out and try it
you don't know if it will work out or
not you know this this live stream as an
example right hey I want to try doing
live streaming plainly and answering
questions let's give that a shot you
know maybe it works out we doesn't and
there's been a ton of things that I
tried that that haven't worked out and
that's like I'm so used to the failure
that it doesn't faze me because you
should be failing you want mr.
your failure where I think people put
too much pressure on it to be the thing
each time you do it you get a little bit
more clarity on what what you want and
what you don't want but back to my usual
you know kind of the reishi always loves
the relationship advice I want to go
into a relationship advice you have to
you have to like you know who the person
is for you because you've tried that a
couple people right like yeah you have
to you have to you know in every
relationship you learn from it right you
learn what was right for you you learn
you know what you need in a partner it's
really hard if it's like the very first
verse that you've dated or gone out in
the coffee with that you know you end up
marrying them I'm so the same thing for
the tasks like maybe you get lucky maybe
the first thing you do is something that
you just absolutely love but chances are
it's going to be it's going to be the
opposite like it's gonna take you some
time to figure it out so that's my first
thought and so don't be frustrated just
continue the journey the second part was
around the comment about what developers
can't change the world for any of this
kind of I would start thinking about how
can i change the world being a web
developer and just reframe like that's a
really limiting mindset right what
developers can't change the world so
when you catch yourself well hopefully
you can catch yourself and these
limiting beliefs what can you do why
can't why can't a web developer change
the world what would what would what
does change in the world mean to you and
how can you do that through web design
right I look at I look at Toronto dance
salsa you know we're
we're changing the world one student at
a time you know it's important that that
for me to be a part of any business that
has to be a greater mission attached to
it so that's that's our focus and it's
not just about teaching move that's not
just about making money and so you can
if you're doing web design like if we
try to get practical now an easy thing
to deal with something like I want to be
the web design the web designer for for
visionaries who want to have an impact
right so all of these people who are
trying to go off and change the world
they need a web designer you know why
can't that web designer be you or can
you come up with the you know their
campaigns that you just really love what
they're doing can you be a part of it
and contribute your designs to right
there's just so many of you know other
politicians you want to get involved
with because you love their message
there's so many different ways to do it
but you have to find the one that best
fits you so it starts with defining what
does change in the world mean in your
eyes and then how can web design be a
part of it I think even just asking that
question like even even that we brought
it up there's already some ideas coming
through your head of how you can change
the world by being a web designer it's a
powerful question asks i think would
like if what design is your thing don't
not do it because you feel like it's not
important enough just find a way to make
it more important you may have already
found your thing mmhmm yeah we got a
great great feedback we we also have a
nice suggestion here Jen so much says
Pat Flynn book called will it fly it's a
great book for entrepreneurs and for new
entrepreneurs so have hasslin book will
it fly well looks like I love it yeah
you know I just have to say to Evan it's
so interesting and just with all of the
you know when you're
trying to find out what you want to do
because it I really wholeheartedly
believe that it if you don't get to it
right away like it's inevitable you will
get there and that you had this
incredible video George Lucas he was
talking about how Star Wars was
inevitable he could have in his early
years chosen to you know he chose to do
film school but he had all these other
interest and so he wholeheartedly
believe that no matter what choices he
made whether it's in school or to go do
I can't remember what other interests he
had but he believes that no matter what
decision image he still would have ended
up at Star Wars and I really I really
believe that wholeheartedly like when it
comes to purpose those passions inside
of you that that are so strong like they
will inevitably steer you to where you
are going to going to be and so
sometimes I think we just get too caught
up on all the perfection for making the
perfect decisions how do I get there but
I think it's just it really Star Wars is
coming eventually it's going to get here
just keep doing what you love and all
your curiosity yeah I agree the things
that you the things that you not you
gravitate to you gravitate to for a
reason Oh boom and you're probably
denying yourself for some reason you're
denying yourself because it's not gonna
change the world or your parents don't
agree with you or whatever you you have
a reason to deny yourself I'm trying to
save Jay all right i save Jay I say
Jay I like it um and and it's getting
more and more used to trusting your
intuition and when something when you
have that curiosity and something feels
kind of right just going out and doing
it even if it doesn't quite makes total
sense to you yet and that the start is
super scary but you get more and more
used to it the more you do it like any
other muscle the more you'll get used to
it let's get point I like it thanks the
extra context your machine and go watch
that Chase Jarvis geez charges yeah it's
a good interview were you there with a
live one did you watch a live free sheet
watch after I was so I was really bad i
tried to get back for that one and I i
missed it so i didn't see a lie all
right well cuz i remember you like i'm
busy today but if i had to watch one
interview what would it be I know and I
thought it would I thought I was going
to be able to make it I didn't it's
really sad good all right you're still
you're still alive you're still team is
winning I'm doing well I got I got four
kills one death to assist so believe
team is doing well our team is 23 2 15
ahead so so far so good so far so good
36 and Jay riser help him carry all
right um next question says this is from
mr. le Loup and mr. lube mr. le Loup his
dad has a radio station they're planning
to put on ad spots and they're kind of
disagreeing on how they should go about
this because his dad thinks that you
know they can't proceed in doing ad
spots on their radio station
they're going to need a big team and he
the son disagreed and says we don't need
a big team we just need to contact
companies interested in having their
spots played on a radio station and
basically it's going back and forth
father doesn't want to do it without a
really clear strategy and a big team so
he wants to kind of know what do you
think and do you have any resources for
strategic marketing and a business plan
for adding ads on radio yeah i think if
this is like embrace the the and here i
think it's true that you may not need a
tee but i absolutely would I actually
would not go into this without a very
clear marketing strategy and I think
that starts by knowing who your
audiences I'm not sure how long you guys
have been doing the radio station i'm
not sure if you have a real clear
understanding of who your audience is
but it definitely wants to start with
knowing that and placing ads according
to who you know your listeners are and
then there's a whole bunch of other
things obviously that would be a part of
having that marketing strategy I'm sure
there are tons of people you can model
success so I don't know if there's one
right way but yeah I would not go into
this without having marketing strategy
strategy and a few mr. Rowley who are
really passionate about this you know
you probably don't need a team if you're
willing to do all the work to occur to
research your audience and create the
marketing strategy but you know
definitely model success here
I love it were in the middle of a
massive fight but I gotta kill maybe 20
Jane ticket it's okay we still got the
kill it's Jade birthday you're gonna
kill this Jase birthday now it's all
good it's all good um can you forget the
blushing it I have it I had a train of
thought no worries uh yeah he just had
oh the radio ads radio ads but it's okay
yeah yeah I just yeah so does their
disagreements yeah uh so I'm a big
believer in starting small I love
starting small like everything I do is
certain small and so what I would say is
if this something you really want to do
like go find a way to prove it what's
this what's the starting small version
of this how do you like can you go and
have one conversation with them with a
potential company or sponsor right like
the worst thing to do is go out and so
can you planned yes you need to plan
absolutely if the plan is go out and
hire three sales people to go out and do
this i think it's that's a terrible plan
is you don't know that it works you have
to prove that it works so what's what's
a small way to prove that it works and a
great way to do it is you invest in your
time your energy your hustle into
finding out something that does work so
what is that and i would i get your
father's point of view right it's his
business he built it up he doesn't want
to take risks you know the new
generation always wants to do things a
little bit different than the old
generation that we have you know bold
ideas for change and I get that you want
to put your mark and that's awesome and
I think you should and so it's
understanding from your father's point
of view that he doesn't want to do
anything 22 crazy and so just show them
that you're not risking the business
what you're going to do to make sure
that this is only one small thing that
you're testing out to see if it works
and then take it from there so I would
try to think about what we're going to
prepare think about what the smallest
way to get started on this thing is what
does that look like is it just having a
lunch meeting with a potential sponsor
you know who is that first posture that
you would think of for doing this is
there somebody in your contact block ooh
is the automatic first person that comes
to mind for this right and then whether
you ask your dad or not I'm of I'm of
two minds there it depends on your
relationship like if you really think is
going to say no to having a lunch
meeting then I might just go out and do
it and then prove it like if I was
confident in it I'll often not ask for
permission and just and just and then
just show that a word but then it sounds
like then you gotta show that it works
right then head if it doesn't work out
your ear you know you're a little bit
screwed there so you gotta show that it
works who or the better way probably has
you know in quotations better way is if
you can get his permission in in support
just to do one small simple test and
then take it from there yeah I like it
cool I like it too yeah i mean the cool
thing about the his son and he really
believes in his idea so i think what
you're saying is is he could go out
there and really just hustling maybe
come up with some really cool rizal yeah
but it has to work it has to work if
you're not going to the lion it has to
work yeah great okay next question comes
from
perennial harvest creo harvest says oh
this is just a basically kind of a shot
out Evan he I guess he was in a
conversation with you and he said check
out Brian lander mission and values
podcast he thinks you guys would really
resonate and have he says you guys would
really you know mesh well because you
guys are doing similar things I guess
he's an entrepreneur in LA so there you
go just a little connection there oh
that's that's the whole thing used to
shout it to Brian Landers yeah he wanted
you to connect you I guess you guys had
a conversation he wanted to to suggest
you check out Brian Landers because he
says you remind him you guys remind him
of each other Joe all right well that's
awesome thank you for that maybe tell
him to join our live stream or or cook
us up on email we'll figure something
that Brian Landers awesome next question
comes from Norbert this is gonna be fast
cuz we just won the game Oh anyone had I
don't know I don't want to disrespect
Norbert I know why don't we why don't we
in today I know I just a second / and go
off and like do with two minute answer
we want that was a fast one when yeah
let's see what our final stats are here
the thing with Evelyn is uh she's much
more early game so she she does well at
the beginning okay well I was 8 and 1 J
reyez was 11 and 3 and the trainer 6 was
12 and 9 so Wow yeah we all did pretty
well they're good team yeah good job how
fast was that game 30 minutes that was
pretty fast well
11 we got a quick birthday victory for J
reyez anything recognized in the in the
in the live chat yeah we just had a
actually it was really nice because
bully we had some questions from they
know he was looking for some information
and of course believe nation stepped up
big time and we're providing huge value
for Z know and and sherry was was having
a good time to kind of cutting out a
little bit with her Wi-Fi but just lots
of love and the chat lots of believe in
value being given so tribute to you Evan
in the community here building every day
I love it what's uh what's the final
rishi message of the day to end on the
message today is a cup of cup of trust
because i know a lot of young people out
there especially this happened on
yesterday stream are just really
stressed because they want to find their
purpose they want to know exactly what
they're supposed to do and just I wanted
to encourage everyone but you're going
to get there you know it does not be
perfect just trust that you will get
where you need to be and follow your
curiosity intuition I love it some good
inspiration and on well thank you guys
so much for watching thank you for the
live stream community there too Thank
You Rishi for your great wisdom and the
optimism as usual in the morning that's
it let me know what you guys think in
the comments below continue to believe
or whatever your one word is have a
great day guys and we'll see you soon